for this
a daily drill in Northern Ukraine
just a few kilometers from the
Belarusian border
the hundreds Brigade is a territorial
defense unit
give them former civilians teachers
Builders plumbers who've taken up the
fight
these live fire exercises are
preparation for any possible incursion
border of more than a thousand
kilometers
with this protected stretch now heavily
mined just across this lake is Putin's
closest Ally in the war on Ukraine and
this is the last outpost before you get
into Belarusian territory Belarus has
provided Russia with extensive Military
Support they've even transported Russian
troops into the country but they've
stopped short at sending in their own
soldiers
Russia invaded the country from the
north last February and Ukraine's top
defense officials warn of another
Northern intrusion
but the ukrainians say they won't be
caught off guard again
Captain shows us around and says he's
feeling confident about their defensive
position
foreign
not far from this Fortress are the
communities that straddle the Border
Generations who've never lived anywhere
else now living in the shadow of a
potential new front
Nadia and her daughter Svetlana would
rather die than leave
foreign
[Music]
foreign
fear is building as armies on both sides
prepare for possible confrontation
but little can prepare the people for
what might come
Sky News Valencia Ukraine